seguimos en directo a América edición
nocturna con nuestra sección de economía
para ello contamos un día más con
nuestro compañero Jorge Hurtado Jorge
hoy vamos a hablar de el fortalecimiento
del dólar y su impacto en la economía
global que nos puedes contar bueno Y es
que el índice del dólar estadounidense
que mide el dólar frente al Euro el yen
y otras Divisas importantes subió más de
un 14% solamente este año si se compara
con otras inversiones la ganancias son
aún mayores esto tomando en cuenta
Rodrigo que las acciones estadounidenses
cayeron más del 19%, el bitcoin está más
de la mitad por debajo de su valor y el
oro perdido más del 7%. el dólar sube
principalmente por el aumento en los
tipos de interés en Estados Unidos la
mayor Economía del mundo en ese país
tiene la inflación más alta en cuatro
décadas y registra un mercado laboral
sólido así como otras áreas de la
economía como el sector de los servicios
esto motiva a la reserva Federal o el
Banco Central de ese país a encarecer el
valor del dinero subiendo los tipos de
interés de referencia
conversamos antes con Jorge Hernando
García Castro él es experto en mercado
financiero si le preguntamos
precisamente por qué sube el dólar
el dólar sube porque Se incrementa la
aversión al riesgo en los mercados
financieros es decir disminuye el
apetito por activos de riesgo o
disminuye la tolerancia por activos de
riesgo por lo tanto los agentes de
Mercado y quedan posiciones en este tipo
de activos y se van a tomar posiciones
en los instrumentos de deuda soberana
estadounidense de corto plazo los
famosos tracho de Bills y esto generan
el corto plazo una sobre demanda de
dólares estadounidense lo que tiene como
consecuencia en ese corto plazo una
apreciación de dólar estadounidense con
respecto a las demás Divisas
recientemente hemos visto que pasamos de
un escenario de aterrizaje suave en el
que se espera que los bancos centrales
de las principales economías del mundo
lograrán
ralentizar
la economía
para controlar los precios sin generar
recesión económica sin embargo estamos
viendo que cada vez nos alejamos más de
ese escenario y que cada vez toma Más
verosimilitud un escenario de hacer de
aterrizaje forzoso pero Jorge si mis
conocimientos de economía no fallan un
dólar fortalecido trae buenas y malas
noticias para la economía global
principalmente malas en el escenario
actual de una inflación generalizada ya
que varias empresas en el mundo
comienzan a reportar pérdidas económicas
precisamente por este fortalecimiento
esto porque un dólar más fuerte
disminuye el valor de los ingresos
extranjeros de las empresas cuando se
convierten nuevamente en dólares
mientras los productos fabricados en
Estados Unidos son más caros en el
extranjero recientemente
advirtió que la fortaleza del dólar
podría eliminar 800 millones de dólares
de sus ventas en todo este año brother
en glamble también espera un golpe de
900 millones en el año fiscal 2023 por
estas mismas causas y según bloomberg la
fortaleza del dólar podría afectar la
ganancia de un tercio de las empresas
del índice esmp500 especialmente en los
sectores de bienes de consumo materiales
tecnología y comunicaciones otro estudio
del banco famerica revela que cada
aumento del 10% del dólar es una pérdida
del 3% de la ganancia de las acciones en
los mercados bursátiles al respecto esto
Dijo nuestro invitado
muy fuerte genera también una pérdida de
competitividad de la oferta exportable
estadounidense encarece la oferta
exportable estadounidense
abarata las importaciones para los
Estados Unidos lo que le resta presión a
la inflación en ese país pero genera un
fenómeno de exportación de inflación es
decir
esa fortaleza del dólar claramente
genera más inflación en el mundo entero
para las compañías estadounidenses
aquellas con presencia global aquellas
que tienen una parte importante de sus
ingresos generada en mercados por fuera
de los Estados Unidos pues esto no es
bueno Dado que los flujos de caja que se
generan en eso es Otras economías donde
tienen presencia producto de su
operación pues van a experimentar una
pérdida de valor en dólares como
consecuencia de esa apreciación del
dólar respecto a esas otras Divisas de
esas economías
una pérdida de valor por ejemplo en
dólares de los dividendos a repatriar de
estas multina estadounidenses una
pérdida de valor en dólares de ese
capital invertido en esos países bueno
Jorge muchas gracias por este repaso
económico te invito ahora al igual que a
nuestros espectadores a que sigan con el
nuevo programa que tenemos aquí en
directo América edición nocturna una
semana en el mundo